hallo mein Name ist willkommen meine
Damen und Herren ich zeige euch heute
nur von der rechten Seite da ich links
voll auf die Fresse bekommen habe
und wie war eure Woche so dass ich so
viele von euch gewünscht haben dass ich
mal wieder ebay
fails hochladen machen wir das heute und
starten direkt mit einer Wohnung im
Zentrums nahe Lage für 400 € man denkt
dann vielleicht dann irgend eine schöne
20 30 Quadratmeter Wohnung irgendwo
mitten im Zentrum für Studenten 400 €
setzen auch nicht allzu viel allerdings
kam dass er dabei raus
und das und eins zu eins Köln sein beim
Nächsten lieben
Käufer gefragt könnte man sich den Tisch
gegebenenfalls mal anschauen und der
Verkäufer hat geantwortet an Dich möchte
ich nicht verkaufen danke für dein
Interesse du bist mir zu tätowiert alles
klar wir haben 2022 ihr könnt ja
wahrscheinlich alle Dornröschen es ist
ja dieses Märchen wo die ihr harder
irgendwie runter lässt und dann klettert
irgendwie so ein Idiot die die Wand hoch
anstatt irgendwie den Fahrstuhl zu
benutzen so oder so gibt es von
Dornröschen natürlich auch ein Schloss
zu kaufen auf eBay verkauft jemand der
allerdings keine Ahnung davon hat und
nennt das ganze Döner Röschen Palast
anstatt Dornröschen verlassen
das wäre tatsächlich wahrscheinlich ich
als Vater später hier wurde auf jeden
Fall ein Seat Leon 2.0 tdi dpf fr keine
Ahnung was das alles bedeutet ihr wollt
ihr auf jeden Fall für knapp 5000 € auf
Ebay eingestellt und man erwartet dann
vielleicht so ein Bild im Handy
aufgenommen vielleicht im besten Falle
mit einer Kamera und von verschiedenen
Seiten etc pp die Person hat allerdings
einfach ein Blitzerfoto genommen
wie er mit dem Auto geblitzt wurde
hier verkauft jemand ein Handy für 20 €
und schreibt dazu verkaufe dieses Handy
Handy ist nicht im Bild da ich jetzt für
das Foto machen gebraucht habe Handy ist
so lang und so breit und das
sind die Bilder
er hat halt nicht mehr dazu geschrieben
Watte für ein Handy ist hier wird eine
therapiepuppe für 45 € verkauft und bei
dem Wort therapiepuppe denkt man
vielleicht dann irgendwie eine schöne
Puppe die in einem Kind dabei helfen
kann wenn keine Ahnung wie die Eltern
getrennt haben das Kind ist traurig oder
so und dann spricht das Kinder mit der
Puppe oder Therapeutin anstatt sich der
Therapeutin direkt zu treffen
auf jeden Fall eine Puppe sein
anvertrauen kann vertrauenswürdig aus
die sympathisch aussieht und nicht so
was
also sorry selbst als Erwachsener hätte
ich Angst vor dieser Puppe hier werden
Capri Sonne Strohhalme verkauft aus
Plastik und wir wissen ja schon dass die
ziemlich hoch gehandelt
boah der war richtig peinlich Alter wir
wissen ja auf jeden Fall schon dass
Capri Sonne Strohhalme aus Plastik
ziemlich hoch gehandelt werden auf Ebay
was ich allerdings noch nie gesehen habe
ist ein
290 € Preis mit auch noch
6,75 € Versand das hier ist der nächste
ebay fail und zwar wird hier ein Brett
in hundeoptik für 50 € verkauft und das
hier ist das Foto
und das ist nicht gephotoshopt ich
schwöre euch dieses Brett hat wirklich
die Optik von einem Hund ich habe auch
die Optik von dem Hund hier wird ein 12
Personen Zelt für 20 € verkauft man
fragt sich jetzt vielleicht hey wie
können die ein 12 Personen Zelt für 20 €
verkaufen wie kann denn ab 12 Personen
Platz kriegen na ja
die haben sich da auf dem Festival so
ein bisschen reingequetscht aber das
hier bringt jetzt wirklich überhaupt
nichts mehr ne da kann man ja komplett
durch komm wir machen das jetzt einfach
so ist egal wenn man erstmal nur das
Bild hier sieht denkt man sich eventuell
Mensch da verkauft jemand eine Flasche
Havana klappt mit Cola und Glas oder
vielleicht ist es eine limitierte
Version oder irgendwie so aber nein
jemand verkauft für 500 € das er für
einen Saufen geht auf Male beim nächsten
Kleinanzeigen fail haben sich der Käufer
und der Verkäufer schon auf einen Deal
geeinigt und das einzige was noch fehlt
ist das Abstimmen der Uhrzeit wann der
Gegenstand abgeholt wird von daher
schreibt der Interessent ja okay wann
haben Sie Zeit heute um 13 Uhr um 17 Uhr
geht ja würde auch gehen okay dann komme
ich um 13 Uhr dicker
hier wird ein Nissan verkauft also ein
Auto jedoch muss das Auto selbst
abgeholt werden steht da in Klammern
Hintern vielleicht Mensch vielleicht
schafft die Person ist einfach nicht
zeitig das Ding zu bringen es gibt doch
einen Sinn dass ein Auto selbst abgeholt
werden muss weil sonst irgendwo
hinfahren oder mit der Bahn zurück oder
irgendwie so nein
das Auto
ist einfach irgendwie ich also ich kann
nicht mal wie das dahin gekommen ist
aber gut Freunde machen wir weiter mit
dem nächsten Überfall und zwar wird hier
ein Sack verkauft oder fragt man sich
jetzt natürlich erstmal wieso verkauft
man einen sagt das ist ja nichts was man
kauft nutzt
einfach aber eigentlich dann wieder
verkauft weil du kaufst eigentlich
einmal und dann
ist Ruhe also was sind so das wirklich
Ruhe naja egal auf jeden Fall wird der
Sarg verkauft wegen falscher Diagnose
und dementsprechend ist ja auch noch
unbenutzt für 300 Euro und das ist
glaube ich vor realen Ernstes Angebot es
ist aber auch ziemlich blöd gedacht wenn
du dir einen Sarg kaufst
obwohl eine Person noch nicht mal tot
ist menschlich gesehen ziemlich abstoßen
was ebenfalls menschlich gesehen
ziemlich abstoßen ist ist tatsächlich
dieses Auto wurde ja auch schon
zahlreiche Male zum hässlichsten Auto
der Welt gewählt ich weiß auch nicht was
sie sich dabei gedacht haben das sieht
aus wie so ein verkrüppelter Wahl billy
ist allerdings anscheinend an diesem
Auto interessiert und fragt
dementsprechend ist das still available
also ist das Auto noch zu haben morgen
antworte daraufhin tatsächlich Morgen
und nicht übermorgen morgen antwortet
die auf jeden Fall jetzt woraufhin Billy
wieder schreibt not surprised
guten Abend ich hätte Interesse an
Haarverlängerung liebe Grüße guten Abend
dann sollten wir zunächst einen Termin
für einen unverbindliches
Beratungsgespräch vereinbaren wann würde
es ihnen denn passen liebe Grüße kann
man bei Ihnen auch Ratenzahlung machen
diese Leute die zu viel liebe Grüße
wünschen meine Mom gefühlt die schreibt
mir Luca kannst du Brötchen holen die
begrüße so die schreibt hinter alles
liebe Grüße Mama bis zu Hause ja liebe
Grüße hier verkauft jemand einen Opel
Astra und schreibt in die Beschreibung
scheiß Astra geht 2.0 16V Kern Schrott
explodiert wir verkauft jemand eine
Jeanshose für 150 € und das
ja
sage ich jetzt nicht so von daher machen
wir direkt weiter mit dem nächsten ebay
fail und zwar diesem Chip das ist
nämlich ein ganz normaler Pringles der
irgendwie umgeknickt ist dann hat man
ziemlich häufig in der Packung aber da
steht runter selten Pringles Sammler
Sammler Chip mit Klick für 50 €, ich
habe auch einen Knick
in der Optik
hier wird ein Bus verkauft und zwar wird
er nicht nur verkauft sondern wird sogar
günstig abgegeben weil er nur dreimal
benutzt wurde und jetzt fragt man sich
vielleicht welcher nur dreimal benutzt
der von der deutschen
Fußballnationalmannschaft die bei der
letzten WM komplett reingekackt haben
nächstes Jahr in Deutschland
ich sehe da komplett schwarz wie Idioten
spielen momentan
ich sehe da mindestens genauso schwarz
wie mein Auge hier verkauft jemand einen
Tiefkühlschrank
Mann ich habe es nicht safe in die Hose
geschissen hier verkauft jemand auf
jeden Fall eine Tiefkühltruhe aka tiefer
Gefühl Schrank
Deutsch können die irgendwie alle nicht
ne kommen wir nun allerdings auch schon
zu den letzten drei ebay kleinanzeigen
fails für heute und diesen mal wieder
Reime machen wir häufiger mal am Ende
von daher rosen sind rot die Elbe ist
ein Fluss Schlafcouch zu verschenken
weil mein Freund ins Gefängnis muss
rosen sind rot für mich ist Gott weder
Frau noch Mann ich bete ein
Fahrradträger für Wohnwagen an was rosen
sind rot Computer haben häufig Macken
mein Freund ist ein Tiger doch ich nenne
ihn Microsoft Lappen und an der